so we're going to follow up a bit on the
VPN video we did the other day one of
the things I mentioned in that video is
how VPNs often use UDP or raw IP sockets
to send the data rather than using TCP
to communicate which is what lots of
other protocols like HTTP and so on use
it to communicate I thought it'd be a
good idea to follow up on why they use
UDP rather than TCP because if they did
use TCP you would suffer from what's
been dubbed the TCP meltdown problem and
so it's good idea to look at this
because we actually get to see a lot of
how the internet works and having make
sure that the data that's sent from
yours and the server to the client gets
there a library or vice versa so to
understand what's going on it helps to
sort of think about how the internet
works now the internet is built around
the Internet Protocol IP which is
designed to enable a computer to send a
packet of data so a small amount of data
anywhere on the internet so it can take
that piece of day to its a destination
address of a wants to go a source
address and IP says I will send this
packet out anywhere over the Internet to
where you want it to go so I can send it
from my house to Shawn's house I can
send it from my house to Microsoft or
Apple servers to get a webpage whatever
it is I want to do now IP says I will do
my best to get this packet to you I will
try and pass it on but something may go
wrong I might have it may not get there
and in that case well it's what's called
a best-effort network IP doesn't
guarantee that it will get your packet
from point-a your machine to point B the
destination it says it'll do its best
it's not what we'd call a reliable
network reliable network is one where
when you send some data it'll guarantee
that it'll be received or it'll tell you
that it hasn't been received IP doesn't
do that IP is a best-effort network
it'll do its best to get there and these
days probably 99 out of 100 times
whatever the percentages are the packet
will get there but occasionally there'll
be a sort of splat of noise on the one
of the networks somewhere that
obliterates the packet a computer will
have too many packets arriving at it and
one will get dropped it just won't get
there that's just the way the internet
works it doesn't guarantee that your
data will get from A to B now this
sounds
it should be a problem but actually what
we can do is we can build other things
on top of that unreliable Network which
give us reliable transport so we can
send things over that network but as it
stands it's worth remembering this
because part of the reason that we get
this TCP meltdown problem IP is an
unreliable network
it also doesn't guarantee that the
packets you send will arrive in the
order that you send them and there's no
correlation between the packets you
sense and packet packet packet and they
arrive at the other machines as separate
packets it's up to the other machine to
sort of understand how they get there
and it's worth remembering these three
things because these are part of the
problem that leads to TCP meltdown so
even though IP doesn't give us a
reliable Network this isn't a problem
for the internet because we can build
other things on top of that and one of
the things that we use is TCP TCP / IP
TCP stands for the transmission control
protocol or TCP does is it uses IP
packets in a specific way between the
two ends of the connection to guarantee
a reliable connection between the two
machines what this means is when you
send data you guarantee we feel arrive
in order down that TCP connection it'll
guarantee that they all get there and
they will correlate them together so you
can open a connection between two
machines and the data sent down one will
arrive to the program at the other as
it's expected so this is guaranteed by
TCP and it does that by using the
unreliable IP packets in a specific way
but it's built on the assumption that IP
is an unreliable network that the
packets may get lost they may arrive out
of order and so on subject and it has to
take that into account again that comes
down to part of what is the problem if
you try and build a VPN on top of TCP so
know that it doesn't work is that the
performance drops and it will become
really really slow when actually you
could get it much faster think so what's
going on what it's worth looking at
actually how TCP works we can see there
and then we can see what happens when we
put one TCP connection inside another
TCP connection which is what would
happen if we ran a VPN over the top of a
TCP connection when we send data over
TCP ocean we have a stream of data that
we're going to send from one computer to
the other
DCD and so I'm gonna send that in order
it's going to arrive in order
what CCP does is it breaks that up into
a series of packets so we've got five
packets what it does is it puts a TCP
header which contains some information
so that TCP can reassemble the stream at
the other end so it adds an extra header
in there so as well as the IP packet
header we've also got a TCP packet
header in there as well I'm drawing this
in red on top of the plackets and then
just to pick another color at seven i
screen you've got the sort of IP header
on there as well so we've got a series
of packets we went saying containing
some data in this case numbers 1 2 3 4 5
and they wrapped up in the TCP header
and they wrapped up in the IP header as
well and then they're sent out over the
Internet but what does TCP need to do to
make sure that it can reassemble this
data in the right order well the first
thing it does is in the TCP header it
gives each packet a sequence number and
this is just a number that increases
each time it gets sent over the Internet
and now if these packets arrive in a
different order so we get packet 1
packet 2 Paquette 4 packets 5 packet 3
when they arrive because they perhaps
taking different routes around the
internet then the algorithm can reorder
them just by sorting them into the right
order because we can use the sequence
number so it's relatively
straightforward to solve the problem
that the packets may arrive out of order
because we can re sequence it but how do
we solve the problem that a packet may
get lost well the answer is relatively
straightforward let me start another
diagram let's have a think about what
we've got on our two machines we've got
our sending machine here we'll call that
s and we've got our receiving machine
over here we'll call that R and this is
going to send packets to the other
machine so it'll send packet one over to
the machine that'll take some time to
get there but eventually they'll get
there and then it will send packet two
and then it will send packet three then
it sends packet for below so that gets
lost in transmission it then sends
packet five so we've got one two three
four five and at the other end we see
one packet to packet three packet five
now how does the TCP algorithm make sure
that it gets all of them and it can send
the data in the right order
well it's really quite simple what
happens is when the receiving machine
has received a packet of data it sends
back an acknowledgement packet so it
just sends to the other machine yep I
received packet one yep I received
packet two and at this point the sender
knows the packet one's been received
correctly he gets the acknowledgement
from packet 2 he knows that that's been
received correctly he gets the
acknowledgement from packet three knows
that that's been received correctly but
he never gets an acknowledgement from
packet for because he was never received
and then eventually will get an
acknowledgement from packet five so if
we send an acknowledgement of receipt we
say to the thing that sent it yep I got
packet one or whatever the sequence
number we've put on it yeah I got packet
two or whatever the sequence number uh
put on it then the other end knows that
that's been received what does it do
when they get lost well at the same time
is transmitting a packet so when it
transmits packet 1 it also puts a copy
of packet 1 in what's called the
retransmission queue and when it sends
packet 2 he puts a copy of packet 2 in
there and it puts packet 3 packet for
and packet 5 and when it puts these
packets on there it sets a countdown
timer with them they're after a certain
amount of time will expire at that point
if it hasn't received the acknowledgment
and as soon as it's been lost retransmit
it and then restart the countdown again
and so if the technology isn't received
either because the packet didn't get
there or because the acknowledgement got
lost on the room which can happen that's
not a problem then the packet will get
sent again and because TCP keeps track
of the sequence numbers if it gets to
placate if the acknowledge will get lost
that's not a problem either it can
eventually we'll get all the packets and
Cannery sort them into order now it
doesn't actually work exactly lies it's
not sending a packet than working for
acknowledgment sending a packet what it
uses is also a thing called a window on
the receiving end which says you can
send up to this many
packets before I'll send an
acknowledgement for you effectively is a
bit more complicated than that but
that's the general gist so that you
don't have to keep waiting for it and
you've made the most use of the
bandwidth between the two machines so
there's a bit of optimizations there but
you now have a problem how long do you
wait before we send in that packet and
how many packets do you allow to be
built up in that window before you stop
sending it this very much depends on
your network conditions if you've got a
very fast local area network waiting 30
seconds for a packet before you resent
it is probably not using the network
that well because if you haven't
received the acknowledgment probably in
a few microsecond a few and milliseconds
chances are you're not going to receive
that packet likewise waiting a few
seconds on a very congested slow link
particularly when TCP was created in the
80s perhaps a sort of 56 kilobit Network
link waiting a few seconds probably
wouldn't be a good time either because
the chances other network is more loaded
so what TCP does is it analyzes this
thing as it starts sending data so it
starts in the data out and you look at
what's happening how long it's taking
for the acknowledgments to be returned
how quickly the windows getting filled
up and so on and it adjusts both the
window size and the retransmission timer
on the fly to find the best performance
for that network at that point so that's
what it's doing and it's doing that
because it knows that the network it's
transmitting over is unreliable the
packets may get lost and that they may
arrive out of sequence so it can reorder
them using the sequence numbers
it sends acknowledgements and so on in
those that the packets may get lost as
they're being transmitted it knows that
they may arrive out of order so by
giving the sequence numbers on there by
using the acknowledgments back to the
thing that was sending it's able to
correct for these things and analyze the
network connections to make best use of
the available network at that point in
time and that generally works in most
cases pretty well in the Internet is
generally able to even utilize all the
bandwidth that's available between two
people when TCP works well we talked
about in the previous video how I might
connect using a virtual private network
over the internet from my machine at
home to my business call
well I want to access resources on or go
out over the internet from that and so
on so if I create my VPN using a TCP
connection between my machine at home
and the business corporate network I've
created a reliable connection which
guarantees every byte of data I sent
will arrive and it will arrive in the
order I send it it's very different from
what TCP is expecting when it sends
packets out using IPS expecting the
exact opposite that when I send data
they might get lost and they might
arrive out of order so what happens is I
take the date I'm going to send in my
virtual private network I wrap it up in
the TCP header there and then wrap it up
in an IP packet header and then I put
that IP package into another TCP stream
and that gets sent to the business that
way this is going to get complicated so
let's call the ones at the very top TCP
one they're the ones that are being sent
over the virtual connection and the ones
that are being used to form and the
virtual connection will call TCP to just
give them different names
so these TCP Wan packets get sent out
and if everything's five the network is
working fine or it'll generally work
okay you can do this the packets will
get there
it's just that they can sometimes go
horribly wrong now let's think what
happens if TCP to the lower level on the
virtual link TCP to effectively a packet
goes missing
what arrives out of order as a packet
goes missing that lower-level TCP to
connection will ask for the packet to be
resent and so it will send the data
again however many times that's needed
and so on until it gets sent across and
it's then passed up to TCP one which
gets it but TCP one says hang on this
didn't come as quickly as I expected
something's going on here and you
probably find the sender at that point
said oh I haven't heard the up I
expected this connections a bit slow so
I better slow down sending things out
and because TCP two had delayed this so
arrived in order it arrived at TCP one
also delayed and so the sense that
it was slow as well and it might have
already freeze we tried to transmit this
at the TCP 1 level which means there's
more packets going to TCP 2 than the
necessary and very quickly you find the
two algorithms start to fight each other
and TCP ones algorithm will start
sending more packets thinking they're
getting lost while TB TB 2 will be doing
its best to make sure they get there in
the order that they're sent and so what
we'll end up is that the performance
will drop of your network connection
because the two algorithms are trying to
fight each other
now if you use UDP which is what most we
decree PN things do you DP doesn't
provide any guarantees that packets will
get there all it does is sort of
multiplex things so you can have more
than one connection between two machines
it's got port numbers and able to do
that those packets can still get lost at
a lower level so you only have one
algorithm TCP one at the top would now
be running over UDP the packet gets lost
TCB one knows it's got lost at the point
it's got lost and so the algorithm works
as expected because it's got the same
assumptions that it's expecting
underneath for the lower level Network
which is why wherever possible most VPNs
will use UDP or all IP packets because
they provide the same level of
assumptions that TCP is expecting it was
built it's a bit more complicated that
but you get the general gist of what's
going on that'll be the internet after
those machines can also access the
Internet via the router and the Richer
can act as a firewall so that people
can't get into it using the k80 session
key we've just obtained so k80